disco delivers affordable science-backed
skin care treatments to your home the
disco starter set helps guys fight oily
skin and razor burn and keeps your skin
hydrated i've had great results with it
you'll get 30 off at letsdisco.com
pacman the link is down below
all right welcome everybody um i think
we're sort of at a point where it makes
sense to issue a reminder and go through
the data
that there is still no actual evidence
that the covet vaccines approved in the
united states have caused even one death
even a single death and i had people
yesterday sending me
links to the joe rogan sanjay gupta
interview i had links to articles based
on vayer's reporting and
it just is a good time to refresh what
is actually known about the vaccines now
this is not a segment about the russian
vaccine this is not a segment about the
chinese vaccine and what they have or
haven't done i just don't have data that
i can look at that i could say with any
um certitude that is reliable data i'm
not saying anything one way or the other
about those vaccines i just want to be
clear that if you're going to email me
things about the russian vaccine i am
doing a segment here specifically about
the pfizer vaccine
the moderna vaccine and the johnson and
johnson vaccines approved and available
here in the united states and on those
there is no clear evidence whatsoever
that they have caused any deaths in the
united states now this is different than
have any vaccinated people died of covid
last time
two months ago i did a similar segment
with the data we had until then and
people wrote to me and said david sir
actually they didn't say sir they were
less polite they said david you're lying
there are plenty of vaccinated people
that have died that's different the the
the question here is have the vaccines
caused deaths
uh a couple of weeks ago we had a very
detailed report from the cdc with the
latest data on adverse reactions to the
vaccine now it's important to remember
just because someone submitted a report
of a death caused by the vaccine to the
veyers system va ers doesn't mean that
someone actually died as a result of the
vaccine as the cdc reminds us and i
encourage you go through this article
we're linking to this a cdc page
um
adverse events described on this page
have been reported to the veyers system
veyers accepts reports of any adverse
event following vaccination that doesn't
even mean
related to the vaccination and we'll
talk about that in a second
um also remember that the fda i'm sorry
the uh yes the fda
requires that health care providers
report deaths that take place after
covet vaccination
even if the health care provider has no
real reason to think that the death is
related to the vaccine it's just it
happened after the vaccine sometimes
people die weeks after the vaccine has
nothing to do even with covet never mind
the vaccine it's still supposed to be
reported and then evaluated and again
anybody can submit such a report as it
says here reports of adverse events to
vayers following vaccination including
deaths do not necessarily mean that a
vaccine caused a health problem
so what
has the cdc put out and this is the
their latest report it's a couple weeks
old now about vaccine reactions and
adverse events
it's a matter of reading through these
one by one and understanding them first
anaphylaxis after covet 19 vaccination
it's rare
it's occurred in two to five
out of every million vaccinated people
in the united states
severe allergic reactions including
anaphylaxis can occur after any
vaccination if it occurs vaccination
providers can effectively and
immediately treat the reaction that's
not unique to the covet vaccine
and it is extraordinarily rare
and treatable okay
thrombosis with thrombocyte
syndrome after the jnj vaccine is rare
as of october 6 about 8 days ago more
than 15 million doses of the jnj vaccine
were given there have been 47 reports of
people who got the vaccine and later
developed tts thrombosis with
thrombocytopenia syndrome
concentrated among women under 50 years
old
okay
to date
two confirmed cases of tts
have been reported with moderna after
382
million doses so extraordinarily rare
we then have as has been the case with
other vaccines in the past gbs
guillain-barre syndrome and people who
got jnj
very rare disorder
15 million jnj vaccines administered 228
preliminary reports
and those have to be looked at more
closely
typically men over 50. so we talked
about tts
very rare concentrated in women under 50
with the jnj gbs very rare concentrated
in men over 50
with the jnj
we then heard of myocarditis and
pericarditis after covid19 very rare
1640 reports invaders and again remember
anybody can submit that and there's no
question there's a bandwagon effect if
people stop submitting submitting
submitting you should look at what's
been submitted to theirs 1640 submitted
among people under 30
most cases
reported particularly in adolescent
males and young adults through follow-up
including medical records review the cdc
and fda have confirmed about half 926
reports
and uh the relationship to
uh vaccination is still being
investigated um and then reports of
deaths
this is a really important thing because
veyers has received 8 600 reports of
deaths
but
even linking them causally to the
vaccine
is not something that has been done yet
when you give hundreds of millions of
people a vaccine
by sheer actuarial reality the fact that
people die
people are going to die in the days
weeks and months after receiving a
vaccine that's supposed to be reported
to vares even if it's not believed to be
because of the vaccine and there is
every reason to believe there are lots
of false reports uh but it is really
important that we go by what the cdc
has assessed based on the data now what
about blood clots that's another one
that we've been hearing a little bit
about
researchers are still looking at whether
there's any connection between j and j
and a rare type of blood clot
very very few cases still being
investigated and once we have something
more definitive on that we will talk
about it so
when you hear the talking point is
basically look at all of the deaths that
have been reported people talk about
tens of thousands hundreds of thousands
of deaths due to the vaccine the actual
number of deaths reported to the system
is 8 600
and
there has been no confirmation that it
is because of the vaccine
there are deaths that took place after
individuals were vaccinated that's the
data i have no interest in hiding or
exaggerating or downplaying anything
that is the data as we know it right now
and with time we will continue to get
updated reports
we actually got some really good
economic news this morning that i want
to talk about a little bit
now we are now at the pandemic low for
new unemployment claims these are
reported weekly uh jobless claims
another 293 000 people
filed new claims last week that is the
new pandemic era low and we've
subsequently hit lower and lower lows
the u.s posted a much larger than
expected drop in initial unemployment
claims last week bringing the numbers of
those newly unemployed back toward their
pre-virus pace the labor department
released jobless claims this morning
um initial claims ended for the week
ended october 9 that's last week 293 000
was the actual number of new jobless
claims they were expecting 320 000 in
terms of continuing claims
2.59 million
versus
2.67 million expected
these are the smallest number of new
filings since march of 2020
and jobless claims have been inching
closer and closer to pre-pandemic levels
so there's a slowdown in firings
layoffs and separations reopenings are
taking place demand for workers is
resurging so there's a few different
stories here
first is
there's the narrative from the right
about lazy people who now want to stay
home and collect enhanced unemployment
the enhanced unemployment is uh i
believe is over in all states although
there may be some states that still have
funds left and are continuing it but at
the federal level the enhanced
unemployment is done as predicted there
were relatively few people who were
literally saying i would rather just
collect unemployment than work although
any social insurance system is going to
have some free riders we don't really
care about free riders as long as the
system at the macro level is well
calibrated and achieves what it's
supposed to achieve enhanced
unemployment was actually one of the
biggest saving graces for millions of
people during the pandemic the fact that
there were some free riders i'm sure
doesn't really change that but as
expected as it is phasing out people are
getting back to work new jobless claims
are going lower and lower and lower and
are almost indistinguishable now from
the numbers we were seeing shortly
before the pandemic so we've almost
zeroed that out
number two point that's relevant here
there have been those on the right uh
opportunistically saying
that vaccine requirements and mandates
are going to keep unemployment rates up
because people are going to say oh i've
got to be vaccinated or oh i've got to
be tested no i'd rather not work
unemployment or not that doesn't seem to
be happening it never passed the sniff
test to begin with and it doesn't appear
to be happening as the new unemployment
numbers keep going lower lower and lower
um a few other uh there's actually a
graph here that we can look at
um u.s jobless claims reach fresh
pandemic error low as you can see there
was this major major spike in april of
2020 where there were between six and
seven million new claims and uh those
continued to decline five million four
million uh then into the threes and twos
we eventually got under the one million
mark uh in the summer last summer august
of 20 etc and basically with just a
little bit of a spike right at the start
of 2021 continuing to decline going
lower and lower now
it's not all uh you know rainbows and
gingersnaps um yahoo finance rights even
as the number of those newly unemployed
improves lingering concerns over the
coronavirus keep a lid on further
progress in the recovery many
individuals still on the sidelines of
the labor force demand for workers has
outpaced supply job openings are at a
near record high of more than 10.4
million in august so there are still
many jobs available many jobs available
rubila faruki who's the chief u.s
economist for high frequency economics
wrote shortages are a severe constraint
of the labor market currently
overall the label labor market remains
on a gradual path towards pre-pandemic
health the slowdown in the pace of job
gains and still depressed participation
rates are reminders that the process
will take some time uh which is fine
um this is uh we don't you know in an
economy
as large as the united states
um
shocks to the system where things happen
as quickly as that which happened in
march and april of 2020 are rare and
they're not good for the economy it's uh
the those are the types of things that
cause further follow-on calamities of
different kinds in terms of supply chain
in terms of all the different things
that we've been talking about so it
would be expected that as we hopefully
gradually continue to see cases decline
deaths decline in the united states that
we would see the labor market recover
but this although these are the best
numbers of the pandemic so far
there are still limitations to the
economy now next week probably next week
we're going to talk about wages because
one of the big
kind of debates that has surfaced in
terms of
we need workers and we can't get them
has been the right saying well you can't
get them because they're lazy people
collecting unemployment at home and they
would prefer to do that
the left has said this is an issue of
you're not paying enough if you want to
get workers free market right offer a
higher wage and then you'll have more
people interested in working for you
we're going to dig into the wage issue
next week uh and look at so-called
various quality jobs high medium and low
quality jobs as they're sometimes
described we're still putting together
all the data we're going to look at that
next week next week if you have a story
to tell
about your employment path and the
decisions you made based on unemployment
insurance that was or was not available
right into info davidpakman.com you can
also find me on twitter at dpakman and
tuesday please don't forget to we've
been planning this me a viewer town hall
now for a few weeks
tuesday october 19th at 6 p.m eastern we
are doing a live stream on the pacman
live youtube channel that's our second
channel
youtube.compacmanlive
i would love for you to call in open to
everybody members will get priority on
the phone lines this will be 6 p.m
eastern
tuesday october 19th hope to see you
there
one of our sponsors is disco there are
so many different types of bogus skin
care products for men out there what you
really want to go with is just something
affordable effective and created by
dermatologists that's why we have disco
which delivers the science-backed
over-the-counter skin treatments that
dermatologists recommend to their
patients every day the disco starter set
is a simple way to take care of your
skin in three quick steps the face
cleanser stick fights oily skin the
exfoliating face scrub prevents razor
burn and the face moisturizer keeps your
skin hydrated disco can also help with
ingrown hairs dry skin acne and other
things you just need 60 seconds a day
i've been using it for a while now i'm
seeing a noticeable difference maybe you
can even tell
check out disco try out the products for
yourself you will like the results and
you'll get 30 off when you go to
letsdisco.com pacman or just enter the
code pacman the link is down below
our program continues to depend on the
support of viewers and listeners to the
podcast to the youtube channel to the
radio show to the tv show i would love
it if you grabbed a membership at
joinpackman.com
we do an extra show every day i mean
this is not just a you do gets that you
do get stuff you get perks we do an
extra show every single day for our uh
members if you are curious about the
whereabouts of producer pat last week on
yesterday's bonus show the october 13th
show pat explains all many people quite
titillated actually by the story some
not so pleased but many people
titillated you can sign up at
joinpakman.com get the bonus show get
the commercial free audio and video
streams of the show
you can also participate for free
in the david pakman show subreddit which
now has nearly uh 33 000 subscribers
uh davidpakman.com
reddit is the place to find it a few
interesting and disturbing posts i found
this morning on the subreddit user
kiddo459
wrote
my wife won't get vaccinated david sir
my wife is anti-vaxx not just for covid
but all vaccines she was of course
vaccinated as a kid but due to online
propaganda she won't take the covet
vaccine and doesn't want our kids to be
vaccinated at all any ideas how i can
change her mind and before you say it
i've already tried withholding sex that
only seemed to encourage her
i i really don't have advice i don't
know
how folks end up with someone with views
so diametrically opposed to their own
now there are some people who have
recently said my spouse
won't let the kids be vaccinated who
said i really had no idea i mean it's
not like my spouse is a right-wing nut
it's not like my spouse has been a
conspiracy theorist in some other way it
came out of nowhere they're just against
the covet vaccine that seems to me like
it would be relatively rare i mean i
guess it's possible that you really
there was no sign whatsoever
but you would imagine that there were
probably some signs that maybe people
didn't notice i don't know but
unfortunately i don't have advice i
don't have advice it sounds like an
extremely extremely difficult situation
which i do not envy
i know that a couple of parents called
in
during live calls a few
weeks ago maybe a couple months
and said i'm thinking of secretly having
the kids vaccinated i'm gonna withhold
that information uh from my spouse
because they will go nuts and i am
determined to get our kid or kids
vaccinated you know that these would be
decisions uh for one to make but i do
not envy the situation
user scheme head is taking issue with
the term vaccine skeptic a scheme head
writes the term skeptic should not be
applied to those still hesitant to take
the covet vaccine skeptics form their
opinions based on evidence and there's
more than enough evidence at this point
showing that the covet vaccines are safe
and effective people who are still
hesitant to take the vaccine are not
hesitant because of skepticism but for
other reasons maybe irrational fear
maybe misinformations maybe my freedoms
but not due to skepticism i think we
should stop using the term vaccine
skeptic
i agree
um first of all hesitant
is often not accurate because they're
not really hesitant they're just not
doing it hesitant would be like oh
i'm about to jump into the pool but i'm
hesitating because it's going to be cold
but then i do it right i hesitated but i
did it
a lot of this vaccine hesitancy is just
people aren't doing it no matter what
and then i agree
we do need a uh
a sort of more
a tougher term
i don't know what the term would be but
i agree that it feels weird to say
vaccine skeptic or vaccine hesitant
because it simply doesn't accurately
describe what's going on and then lastly
a few people uh writing to me and
posting about this article an article on
538 which says it looks like house
democrats are worried about the 2022
midterms you can check out the article
on 538 by nathaniel raykich
and it outlines how there are
a number of house members that are
leaving office
and how that is going to impact the
balance potentially
and the many reasons that democrats
maybe are worried about 2022 and there's
no shortage of reasons to be worried
it's it would be the correct reaction
you if you accurately
and honestly assess
the
circumstances for the midterms democrats
should be worried and many democrats are
in general
midterms after a new party takes control
of the white house don't go well for
that party since joe biden's a democrat
and won the white house you would just
historically it's almost always the case
that you would expect democrats not to
do well in the midterms
you also have because of the uh
retirements and people leaving to do
other things to run for mayor senate
different things um that also
potentially is going to be a problem for
democrats so yeah democrats should be
worried about 2022
and we're going to be talking about it
extensively we already have been to some
degree it makes sense and um we'll get
we'll dig into that more probably really
as soon as next week
join the discussion on the subreddit at
davidpakman.com
reddit hey this is just out of this
world
whacked
donald trump is now saying to republican
voters
if the so-called fraud isn't fixed
for the 2022 and 2024 elections
republicans shouldn't even vote to which
i say absolutely i actually i i would
never go out and say don't vote because
it goes against
my
beliefs about participation in democracy
to tell people to stay home
it just wouldn't feel right
but if trump wants to do it and say to
his republican followers don't vote by
all means that that sounds great to me
so let's talk about what's going on uh
donald trump tells republicans not to
vote in 22 or 24 in a new statement that
he would have posted on twitter himself
if his account wasn't permanently
suspended for inciting violence former
president trump urged supporters not to
vote in the two upcoming elections if
the republican party doesn't quote solve
the supposed voter fraud that he has
falsely claimed precipitated his loss to
president joe biden donald trump's full
statement published to
the desk of donald trump on his website
says
if we don't solve the presidential
election fraud that's capitalized guys
fraud is capitalized if we don't solve
the presidential election fraud of 2020
which we have thoroughly and
conclusively documented that's not true
republicans will not be voting in 22 or
24.
it is the single most important thing
for republicans to do now it's
grammatically ambiguous whether he says
the most important thing to do is to
solve the fraud
or the most important thing to do is not
to vote in 22 or 24 if the fraud is not
solved now
there's two
stories here one is
is trump publishing this just a
distraction and you might say well david
a distraction from what
there is a new report from the house
oversight committee which we will talk
about later in the show which found that
donald trump received millions of
dollars from foreign governments through
the trump hotels
hid his debts and hid his losses it's an
insane blockbuster report so part of it
would be
maybe trump is saying this to distract
from that story and we'll talk about
that later uh the second part here is
that this is the way that narcissists
behave quite frankly um if your parents
say hey little donny it's time to go
home let's leave the sandbox now donny
is the type of kid who would poop in the
sandbox to shut it down so nobody else
can play in the sandbox when trump is
losing at an interview like when he's
not doing well in an interview he's
asking questions that are making him
look bad he walks out or he attacks the
reporter when he's losing elections he
says they're fake and now he's telling
people not to vote
i actually laughed i was thinking about
um when during a press briefing when
donald trump did a press briefing as
president and he was asked uh what do
you say to people who are watching you
right now and are scared
this was when kova deaths were
skyrocketing in 2020 and trump says i
would say you're a terrible reporter
that's what i would say
this is how he behaves and he is saying
i didn't they didn't give me they didn't
let me become president for four more
years
so i'm just going to try to ruin it for
everybody republicans didn't work hard
enough to steal the election for me
nobody did and so now i'm going to say
don't vote and ruin everything for the
party which i think is great i think
it's great now it's it's a it's a very
dire message in a sense in terms of
being a threat to the republican party
trump's saying either get behind me and
support all this crazy stuff i'm doing
and saying or i'm going to actively try
to destroy the party by telling our
voters not to vote in 2022 and 2024.
it's like a trump way or the highway
sort of thing and i absolutely love it
like i said i cannot in good conscience
myself
tell people don't vote don't participate
it's it's it's a form of voter
suppression
i won't do it
but if trump is telling them by all
means listen to the guy if you still
follow him if you trust him if you
believe in him prove it by listening to
what he's saying
these are the sorts of techniques that
would really only work to manipulate
morons and adults quite frankly i mean
that's it
let's be a little more polite low
information voters
ignorant individuals
but
if this is what he's doing let him have
at it and i guess
you know to some degree
trump must see
voting in 22
as acknowledging that the 2020 election
was legitimate i don't even know that
that's really the case i think many
republicans would vote in 22 without
acknowledging that 2020 was legit
for trump it appears that way
and so he's trying to own the libs by
saying don't vote on us please show us
how i challenge these republicans show
us how strong you are
by doing what trump says and not voting
in 2022 and 2024. i won't suggest it but
if trump's saying it go with it i
welcome it and the real question is will
they listen to him will they listen to
him let us know your thoughts we'll have
more coverage of this bizarre but quite
frankly welcomed statement from trump
on the show's instagram davidpakmanshow
on instagram find us there
don't forget that the best way to
support the david pakman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the daily bonus show the regular show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire archive of every episode
dating back
a really long time and plenty of other
awesome membership perks go to
joinpackman.com
and use the coupon code better21 for a
huge discount joinpakman.com
today we're going to be speaking with
jeff duncan who's the republican
lieutenant governor of georgia and also
author of the new book gop 2.0 how the
2020 election can lead a better way
forward for america's conservative party
uh it's great to have you on i
appreciate it yeah thanks for the
opportunity
so okay i mean where to start right
georgia has been at the center of uh
significant political controversy we now
know about the various phone calls and
requests to put it lightly that were
made by former president trump um when
it comes to the results of the 2020
georgia election i mean is it
give us your sense of
the direction that the republican party
has gone relative to where you would
like to see it as a conservative party
yeah there's definitely chaos on the
battlefield for sure and certainly we're
watching that play out in georgia and uh
i think georgia is just a microcosm of
what's what's playing out all over the
country uh you know i'm one of those
people that i'm hardwired to be a
conservative i grew up that way went to
college that way started my first
business raised my family i just believe
in the conservative principles
and so it pains me to watch the
inability to win elections because of a
stylistic because of personalities not
because of our policies
that's painful to watch and that's kind
of the process in the tug of war that
we're in right now
as a republican party that's really what
drove me to write gop 2.0 it's not
really any sort of watered-down
you know policy positions as a
conservative it's just about a better
approach to deliver those policy
positions to america
so did did you vote for donald trump in
2020
i did
i did you know uh
uh i voted for him in 2016. i voted for
him in 2020 i probably fit myself in
that category of tens of millions of of
republicans that did the same thing that
you know really really applauded the the
conservative wins over those four years
but just hard to explain to even my own
kids i talk about this in the book quite
a bit
my three boys really shaped a lot of
uh kind of my positions just in raising
them with my wife uh it was hard to
explain
you know the tweets that went out you
know i'd spend all this time telling my
kids you know hey be careful on what you
do on social media you know and then how
do i explain you know the the former
president doing what he does did
well how did you
how did you explain how did you explain
voting for him then
yeah so interesting i talked a lot about
it in story you know mine was you know i
as i compared the dividing ideas and
plans forward really what i explained or
at least i rationalized in my mind is
really what's playing out right now with
joe biden you know i mean nobody this is
a non-partisan answer to this nobody
agrees in my my mind that the
afghanistan handoff was was the way it
should have been handled uh the way
we're dealing with inflation
the southern border the only person i
mean everybody believes in border
security uh except for joe biden so i
put those elements against what donald
trump had done as a conservative and and
i pulled i pulled the uh the the ballot
for president trump
what exactly would trump have done
differently on afghanistan because he
was actually asked on a newsmax
interview he couldn't articulate a
single thing he would have done
differently
yeah i think looking back uh you know
now in
the hindsight of 2020 monday morning
quarterback looks at he didn't really
have an exit strategy out of there as
thorough as i probably thought he did
uh but uh i hope
that there was enough conservative
leadership in his administration that
would have given him better advice than
what joe biden did and how he executed
uh the the
the exit out of afghanistan right that
would be my hope but it's only it's only
hypothetical yeah no because it seems
since it's the first thing you mentioned
that you're not pleased with in terms of
biden
but then trump can't articulate what he
would have done differently and you sort
of can either other than to say it's a
hope you have it doesn't it it's
interesting to me that that's not
stylistic like at first you said it you
know that they're they're mostly
stylistic
differences with trump but uh but policy
was where
you you would like to see the policies
enacted but then like on afghanistan
it's not really clear the policy would
have been any different so i'm trying to
understand sort of whether your
disagreement is just on style or whether
it's policy as well
well we can split hairs all day long uh
there's a president that's in office and
made the decisions and his name's joe
biden there's a former president that's
not in office that did make those
decisions on exiting afghanistan the
reality is i would have hoped that more
military minds would have made those
realistic decisions and they would have
had more timely thoughtful consideration
for those that helped support our
military those that were
fully expecting to be helped through any
sort of military transition or exit out
of the out of the country i hope is any
president whether a democrat or
republican would have been more
thoughtful for that but that didn't
happen and i think that's the same thing
that we're watching play out with the
southern border
i believe in border security it's one of
the things i talk a lot about in the
book i think republicans have totally
dropped the ball including former
president trump on immigration we spend
all this energy kind of fear-mongering
about the southern border yeah and we
built 460 miles of border wall out of a
what two thousand mile border or more um
and
the reason why i think we've dropped the
ball is we're only having a singular
focused conversation about a big issue
like immigration uh border security but
the the real conversation in addition
has got to be the 16 million
undocumented folks that are here many of
which we have been full force allowing
them to be embedded in our communities
and in our economy and we got to have a
real conversation about that that to me
is an area of opportunity for
republicans to join ranks with some of
the folks on the other side of the aisle
to have those real conversations and i
talk a lot about that
i'm i'm curious uh this is sort of kind
of like uh
it's a sanity check of sorts
when during the 2016 campaign
where where you did end up voting for
donald trump when he said during his
first term he would build a wall across
all 2000 miles and mexico would pay for
it did you believe that for a second i
did
i'm sorry did you say you did not
i did not you did not oh okay
why do you think so many people did
believe that when he said it when it was
so obviously going to not happen
well i think that's the riddle that
we're trying to solve right now as a
republican party is you know how can we
get people away and like this isn't just
a republican problem it's a democrat
problem too
you know america is addicted to 10
second sound bites we're making massive
political decisions and putting our
support behind folks in short clips uh
and certainly gop 2.0 is really trying
to build a much more thoughtful thorough
plan of attack on some of these big
issues ones that aren't in about 280
characters on twitter or about some
slogan called build a wall what really
drew the most higher for the former
president uh to to me specifically
during the 10 weeks of you know my very
intense rebuttal of the conspiracy
theories and the fraudulent you know the
real fraud was talking about fraud in
the election cycle here in georgia um so
my my major pushback really started when
i said look build a wall is a great
project name but it's not an immigration
policy we as republicans need to grasp
on to a serious immigration policy and
start to move forward uh you know i i
that really drew the ire of the former
president and really started a a
visceral downhill spiral on whatever
relationship that was out there yeah so
like what happened during those days
between
election day 2020
where we ultimately learned the margin
of victory for joe biden in georgia
subsequently the phone calls i need brad
raffensberger to find me 11 780 votes
give me a break like what what was what
were you doing at that time who were you
talking to what were the conversations
like
yeah so you know i i literally within
days of the election and all of this
kind of rumor mill starting that there
was fraud and whatnot i i dove head
first into the details i talked to the
governor's office i talked to the
secretary of state
and his entire team i talked to the
attorney general and really the feedback
i was getting is jeff there's there's no
signs of any sort of systemic fraud
there's nothing coming in other than
just wildly placed social media posts
and wild allegations starting to flow in
from the trump administration
so i started to get as quickly as i
could get on tv for for two reasons one
is i didn't want any sort of runaway
rumor to take over the control of the
narrative that that we can run a fair
legal you know legal election here in
georgia and two i was trying to protect
the runoff process from two conservative
u.s senators that were now engaged in a
runoff and
unfortunately we know how that turned
out if you're a conservative
so i hit the tv i i probably did i don't
know what the number is 60 70 80 100
national television interviews and inter
uh radio and music or
print interviews
and i spoke up against it i was one of
the first folks that said unfortunately
i'm gonna have to say joe biden is the
president-elect
uh and and
almost instantly drew ire from not only
the former president
but also from you know
people all over all over the country uh
we ended up you know receiving threats
as a family we had 24-hour security i
mean it was it was an intense 10 weeks
of you know simply
you know just telling the troops
and and one of the surprising things for
me was and one of the motivating factors
behind writing the the book gop 2.0
was
and i thought i was walking out singing
as part of a republican choir but the
reality was i was singing a solo
for far too long
uh when the facts simply lined up that
there was no fraud there was no systemic
issues going on donald trump got beat
and uh he's the one who missed the layup
and as a republican i hold him
accountable for not doing the things he
needed to do to win was there behind the
scenes
any consideration
among brian kemp brad raffensberger and
other election officials of actually
trying to do what donald trump was
asking to have done
so i'll only speak for myself and the
answer is no there was no way i was
going to move my feet this job is not
worth lying for
and i certainly wouldn't lie to 11
million georgians
some of them who who wanted you know to
see the scenario changed but uh i
certainly never heard of any comment i
never had a conversation with any of the
other statewide elected officials that
that ever appeared to me that they were
considering it but i'd encourage you to
get their opinion on that sure so i
guess as
opinions aside as far as you know
no absolutely as far as i know there was
never a consideration uh between the
governor the speaker the secretary of
state and myself to to take into
consideration because look there was
multiple avenues going at this point
there were you know the the former
president wanted to have a special
session to send a different set of
electorates we wanted to have
you know just all types of different
scenarios were playing out that just
really weren't feasible
do you think that
the craziness that took place involving
these fraud claims between november and
the date of the special elections for
the senate which i think was january 5th
do you think that contributed to both
republican senators losing their races
yeah one hundred percent
absolutely uh and it was unfortunate uh
i don't claim to be smarter than anybody
by any stretch of the imagination i'm
just a retired baseball player for the
most part but i could see it coming from
a mile away uh when they by by default
hired donald trump as their campaign
manager during the runoff uh that was
the beginning to the end
um georgians wanted to be reminded of
their conservative policies and and
positions that they stood for they they
you know georgia fell in love with their
business acumen and their ability to
articulate jobs and you know national
security and all those things that
really kind of are the tenants of why
you know we wanted them there and why
the governor hand selected kelly leffler
to represent johnny isaac since the the
remainder of his term
they forgot to do that and uh
unfortunately donald trump got his hooks
in him
and you know just made it all about him
and his conspiracy theories do you think
that trump's actions uh in terms of uh
the influence campaign and the phone
calls
might have been criminal
so i'm not an attorney i i told you i'm
a recovering baseball player
but based on conversations you have
there
yeah so look i i think i think i'll
start with they were absolutely
inappropriate
uh and they were disgusting uh whether i
was a whatever you know party
affiliations were associated with it
they were just inappropriate and uh i
know that there's investigations going
on and they're going to certainly get to
the bottom of what their opinions are
from those legal uh investigations but i
i don't have i don't have the legal
acumen to split hairs and know if it was
illegal or not it was inappropriate for
sure fair uh one of the the criticisms
i've had of the republican party of late
as someone who's not a republican is
that
the focus on policy has become close to
zero and the most prominent republicans
right now that that get headlines
federally are getting headlines by
saying that they don't want to wear
masks or they don't want people to have
to get vaccinated or
they're taking a stance against critical
race theory or
fauci's trying to cancel christmas or
now it's halloween i guess fox did a
bunch of segments yesterday about
halloween maybe getting cancelled
do you think that this is a direction
that's good for just just without
evaluating it morally for winning races
for winning elections is it good to
focus on the culture stuff instead of
policy
absolutely not i spend a lot of time in
the book talking about it uh because
look at the end of the day we're all
supposed to be running for these offices
because we want we want to be in a
position of leadership right and there's
no leadership to be found in all these
short-term sugar high issues i talked
about in the book what i refer to as my
pet project policy empathy and tone
really is the strategy to approve all of
those as a meaningful way to win back
the white house in 24.
and and on the policy front yeah we we
have literally forgotten to remind
america of the policies that we as
republicans are good at just like you
mentioned europe you're you're part of
the you know you're you're a democrat uh
i'm not a democrat i'm i'm on the left
but i'm not a democrat
okay okay so you're on the left so
there's certain issues that you think
the left are better at right that's your
personal position sure well i think
there's some things that americans think
that republicans are better at
we just have totally forgotten to remind
people of those policies that we're good
at and we've also forgotten the ability
to understand that we can lead on some
of these big issues i talked about
immigration a second ago
let's talk about healthcare right it is
a it is an issue right for the picking
to talk about something other than we
hate obamacare
more you know more at 11. right you know
we need to put more on the bone there we
need to talk about how we center health
care
uh away from the government and on to
the small business owners how do we
empower small business owners who by the
way are the bulk of the employers in
this country to be able to to compete
with big companies and with government
programs to be able to offer affordable
health insurance to their employees and
to be able to entice people to come to
work uh instead of just going to the
mailbox to receive those there's so many
solutions that republicans can come up
with healthcare but we got to be willing
to talk about them and not these
sideshows and these distraction elements
and these shiny objects that that really
kind of just run two-day news cycles and
then we then we gotta hurry up find the
next one yeah you you mentioned 2024 and
taking back the white house obviously
before that we have a midterm election
in 2022
do you think that it helps
your
um sort of i don't know that i call it a
side but your approach
to the republican party is it helped or
hindered if folks like marjorie taylor
greene and lauren beaubert and madison
cawthorne get re-elected next year
uh so i don't i don't know
the only person i really know in that
mix uh that i know well is marjorie
taylor green and certainly if we have
more marge retailer greens in uh
congress uh we we're in trouble as
republicans right that's a problem right
and and i certainly have made no no
qualms about it that i think she's
destructive to our state i think she's
destructive to our party i think she a
person like her is destructive to our
country
uh and so it's not just enough to get
republican leadership we got to have the
right republicans that care about the
long-term viability of conservative
leadership and conservative policies uh
that aren't about little side shows and
press conferences and and whatnot um you
know our tone matters you know i talked
about the pet project policy empathy and
tone
our tone is so important if simply
donald trump had a better tone you know
if down the stretch he he he he kind of
became an adult and said you know what
i'm i'm the leader of the free world and
i'm going to use the next 100 days to
really put on display my leadership
style i'm going to take my business
resume on how i can coordinate the
vaccine distribution how i can manage
international affairs how i can manage
an economy that continues to whip saul
and you all just judge me by what i do
not by what i said right just that
better authoritative tone would have
made mountains of difference i think it
would have probably won him the election
uh but of course he couldn't get out of
his own way and i talked about that in
the book with several one-on-one
conversations with him uh in the back of
the beast uh that really kind of led me
to led me to see
that smell in the air of defeat you
could sense even as as close to the
election as two days before donald trump
came down to georgia for a rally in rome
georgia and i was there as one of the
speakers and and this was this was
eye-opening to me i spent a lot of time
in the book talking about this i made a
statement because i was trying to win
the suburbs i knew where we had where we
had to win
was was convince the suburbs that he was
worthy of four more years and i knew it
was going to be close and i made a
statement in kind of closing of my
five-minute speech i said you know what
our policies are so good as republicans
they even help the people that don't
vote for us and i got booed
i literally got booed by a sea of 30 000
make america great hats
because i was willing to say that our
policies are so good to help the people
that don't vote for us too
and that was an eye-opener to me that
one the president was out there
campaigning a hundred miles away from
the suburbs and two
there was such a visceral reaction to
even looking at trying to help the other
side or even trying to build bridges or
expand the size of the tent yeah even
two days before the election the smell
was in the air not just in georgia but
all over the country yeah that's a
definite red flag no no question no
question there the book is gop 2.0 how
the 2020 election can lead to a better
way forward for america's conservative
party we've been speaking with the
book's author jeff duncan who's the
lieutenant governor of georgia really
appreciate your time and your
perspective today
yeah thanks for the opportunity i really
i really appreciate it
if you value what we do at the david
pakman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com david pakman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos the daily bonus show
the commercial free daily show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpakmanshow all right we
have an absolutely huge blockbuster
story based on a report from the house
oversight committee which uh alleges
to have uncovered evidence that donald
trump received millions of dollars from
foreign governments during his
presidency
hid debts
uh concealed losses and we're going to
look at the details of what's alleged
this is sort of like another shoe
dropping as we expected the shoes to
drop after donald trump's presidency
ended and this might actually explain
why trump put out the statement telling
republican voters don't vote in 2022 and
2024 which we covered earlier to draw
attention away from this report and to
some degree it worked
as of this morning if you looked on
reddit on the politics subreddit
the trump telling republicans not to
vote story had 70 000 up votes
trump's major ethics violations had 4
000 upvotes so it quite literally is
working now both are real stories
but if the idea was to obfuscate uh it
it is working in a sense so let's look
at this the house committee on oversight
and reform
committee uncovers evidence that trump
concealed millions in losses
hid debts and received millions from
foreign governments at trump hotel look
at this
let's actually go skip to the second
part
the document provided by gsa documents
raised new and troubling questions about
trump's lease with gsa and the agency's
ability to manage the former president's
conflicts of interest during his term in
office when he was effectively on both
sides of the contract as landlord and
tenant
specifically the committee found that
president trump provided misleading
information about the financial
situation of the trump hotel and his
financial disclosures received
undisclosed preferential treatment from
a foreign bank on a 170 million dollar
loan to the hotel that the president
personally guaranteed
accepted millions of dollars in
emoluments from foreign governments
without providing an accounting of the
money's source or purpose
concealed hundreds of millions of
dollars in debts from gsa when bidding
on the old post office building lease
and made it impossible for gsa to
properly enforce the leases conflict of
interest restrictions by engaging in
opaque transactions with other
affiliated entities as discussed in this
letter
this new evidence raises many questions
that require further investigation and
action by the committee
this is
a crazy amount of alleged wrongdoing and
unethical behavior
it it is stunning the degree to which
this was taking place which we knew
this wasn't necessarily we knew this was
going on we knew it wasn't being
investigated seriously enough it was
obvious that this was going on he was
never he never took care of all of those
those conflicts of interest it's
absolutely wild uh a few okay so the
documents show look at the specifics
here
former president trump reported massive
revenues at the trump hotel
concealing that the hotel suffered 70
million dollars in net losses on his
federally mandated financial disclosures
trump reported that the hotel earned him
over 150 million in revenue during his
time in office but the records obtained
show it actually incurred losses of 70
million leading trump's holding company
to inject at least 24 million into the
struggling hotel by filing misleading
public disclosures trump exaggerated the
health of the hotel he also appears to
have concealed potential conflicts of
interest stemming not just from his
ownership of this failing business but
also from his roles as the hotel's
lender and guarantor of its third-party
loans
while in office trump received
preferential treatment potentially worth
millions from a foreign bank it is
deutsche bank deutsche bank is endlessly
involved every single time there's a new
report about these conflicts deutsche
bank is involved trump did not publicly
disclose the benefits he got
um that it's a deferral that he got the
trump hotel received over 3.7 million
dollars from foreign governments uh we
knew that foreign governments were
staying at trump's dc hotel specifically
to curry favor with them and to
ingratiate themselves with him we now
know it is to the tune of 3.7 million
dollars
uh that is about 7 400 nights at trump
hotel at the average daily rate trump
didn't disclose that to the gsa
and he donated to the treasury only a
small portion of those payments
um and then it goes on and on uh funny
business with the lease related to the
old post office building
um and much much more
this is more of the same stuff that he's
been doing and getting away with for his
whole career he has bragged about it he
says he knows how to work the system
uh he knows how to
uh essentially ignore regulations and
laws and we knew he was doing it on day
one where he showed up with the big
stack of paper and said here's the
paperwork that my attorneys are filing
in order to deal with my conflicts of
interest and we were like are the are
first of all are is the stack even of
is are they blank papers was there was
question one and number two are they
substantively meaningful in terms of
actually dealing with conflicts of
interest and uh it obviously they were
not um this should all be investigated
as many of these seem violations of the
for foreign corrupt practices act which
says it's unlawful for a u.s person or
company
um to offer or pay or promise to pay
money or anything of value to foreign
officials for the purposes of obtaining
or retaining business
uh this seems to have been violated two
ways back and forth for lack of a better
term um this is it it's it's
the frustrating part is
obviously this was going on
obviously it was going on and now it
could take as we've been predicting for
the better part of this year already
it could take years to unwind and
uncover everything that went on
and we probably won't ever really learn
the full extent of it so incredible
revelations here and we'll continue to
follow them up this is kind of it's kind
of funny it's kind of depressing on the
one hand
the
post office as it is currently operating
is operating not as well as it could
thanks to donald trump's selection of
louis de joy to be the postmaster
general
republicans love to attack the post
office they want to damage the post
office and and the reason why is to
encourage private industry to replace it
um
so on the one hand the post office is
functioning poorly because of that and
joe biden can't just replace louis de
joy
joe biden has to wait until he can
replace members of the postal board of
governors
and they can then replace louis de joy
so there's not really that much
um that that biden can do until he's
able to do that
and yet at the same time
reporters are asking jen saki and joe
biden
well
why are packages going to be delivered
more slowly around the holidays here's a
reporter yesterday asking that jen saki
exactly that question take a listen we
can go ahead let me ask that a slightly
similar but different way sure
based on everything being announced
today yeah can
this administration
that holiday packages will arrive on
time
we are not the postal service or ups or
fedex we cannot guarantee what we can do
is use every lever at the federal
government disposal to reduce uh delays
to ensure that we are uh addressing
bottlenecks in the system including uh
ports and the the need for them to be
open longer hours so that goods can
arrive uh and we can continue to press
uh not only workers and unions but also
companies to take as many steps as they
can to reduce these delays now there are
people who reacted and said no no the
government is the postal service it's
it's not okay
the postal service is sort of this weird
in between it's an independent business
enterprise
it's under the purview of the federal
government but joe biden doesn't control
package delivery he doesn't control what
it costs to get a tracking number he
doesn't control the logistics of uh
certified mail or anything like that
it's an independent agency of the
executive branch and the way joe biden
can influence it
is
by choosing appointees by appointing
people to the board of directors who
then can decide do we want to keep
trump's postmaster general lewis to joy
or not now but my best assessment is
that on december 8th
one of trump's postal board appointees
has their term end at that point joe
biden can replace them and it's
believed that that will shift the
balance in the direction of reason and
they will remove louis de joy but it's
this crazy thing
where on the one hand
they are
ignoring the fact
that trump deliberately kneecapped the
postal service through his indirect
influence by selecting louis de joy
that's why things are the way they are
now not because of joe bide joe biden
doesn't get a pick for the board of
governors until december
but then on the other hand they're
asking jen saki can you guarantee
package delivery times no how could joe
biden guarantee that
that's that's not the way the postal
service actually works now whether they
are
deliberately misunderstanding that in
order to ask these questions
to be salacious and provocative and
titillating or whether they genuinely
don't know that that's how it works i
don't know it would it would be a sad
commentary on the state of uh journalism
if they really don't understand
why the postal service is the way it is
right now and it's because louis de
joy's postmaster general
he's postmaster general because of the
choices that donald trump made to the
postal board of governors uh joe biden
will get a shot at changing that
in december
but uh yeah
it's almost like they think biden's
deciding we're gonna slow down package
delivery the way trump slowed down
testing they seem to act as if joe biden
has control just deliver more quickly
and fix the problem i believe this will
be solved
um but it's going to take a little bit
of time and just just pathetic questions
pathetic continued pathetic questions uh
from the white house press corps we have
a voicemail number and that number is
2192 david p this really cracked me up
when i heard it um
yesterday we played this clip of my
pillow mike lindell saying he found out
that a supposedly 850 year old person
voted
uh in the 2020 election that's part of
the fraud here is a caller
making a similar point it's a joke but
they do it beautifully
hey david
this is uh stewart from wisconsin
by the way even the detail of
pronouncing wisconsin wisconsin the way
mike pillow did it this is a perfect
voicemail down to the last detail i have
you know that i know two people who one
is 753 years old and the other is 827
years old
sloan kettering in johnny hopkins and
they used to place that [ __ ] every day
these guys voted can you imagine
it's crazy yeah 753 year olds are out
there voting it's it's wild wild times
um i'm glad
that essentially everybody in my
audience
seems to have realized the absurdity of
of mike pillow's claims
we have a fantastic bonus show for you
today as many of you know
uh gas-powered leaf blowers i believe
are the devil's work i believe they are
the mark of the beast quite frankly
california
is working to ban gas powered leaf
blowers and lawnmowers their motivations
may be environmental
minor sound pollution oriented we will
talk about that also
interest in the flu shot this season is
not very high i got my flu shot we will
talk about
why interest seems to not be very high
on today's bonus show and lastly
we have the first ever approval
for a malaria vaccine
huge we'll talk about the implications
uh and more on today's bonus show sign
up at joinpackman.com you'll get instant
access
to the world famous bonus show i'll see
you then or otherwise we'll be back with
a new show tomorrow
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors disco delivers
affordable science-backed skin care
treatments to your home the disco
starter set helps guys fight oily skin
and razor burn and keeps your skin
hydrated i've had great results with it
you'll get 30 percent off at
letsdisco.com
pacman the link is down below